Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Mes chers amis de TEDx Limoges,
j’aimerais tellement
être avec vous ce soir,
ne serait-ce que pour savoir
si vous faites partie des gens
qui se posent une des questions
que j’entends le plus souvent :
comment est-ce que la magie fonctionne ?
Si vous faites partie de ces gens
qui se posent cette question,
sachez qu’une des raisons
pour lesquelles la magie fonctionne
c’est parce que nous croyons.
Non pas que nous croyions à la magie,
mais plutôt que nous croyons
en la réalité.
Lors de mes spectacles,
lors de mes conférences en entreprise,
j’ai l’habitude de créer des illusions.
En fait, les neurosciences
nous apprennent que
je ne crée pas les illusions.
Les neurosciences nous apprennent que moi,
j’utilise, j’exploite, je détourne
certains des mécanismes de votre cerveau.
Mais celui qui crée l'illusion,
c'est votre cerveau.
La magie n’est finalement pas tant
dans les mains du magicien
que dans l’esprit du spectateur.
Notre cerveau est un véritable
créateur d’illusions,
la plus belle d’entre elles est peut-être
celle que nous appelons réalité.
Notre réalité, en fait, n’est
qu’une représentation mentale du réel,
mais basée sur nos perceptions limitées.
Mais ça va plus loin.
Notre cerveau est véritablement accro
aux illusions qu’il crée
et cette addiction se retrouve dans
plusieurs de nos processus cérébraux.
Il y a tout d’abord
notre système attentionnel.
Chaque seconde, notre cerveau reçoit
environ 400 000 unités d’informations
et sur ces 400 000 unités, seulement 40
seront portées à notre conscience
et donc, intégreront
notre représentation de la réalité.
Celui qui fait ce tri du 1 pour 10 000,
c’est notre système attentionnel,
là où nous portons notre attention.
Cela va intégrer notre représentation
de la réalité.
Ce qui échappe à notre attention,
eh bien, peut-être que nous n’imaginerons
même pas que cela puisse exister.
Ensuite, il y a le fait que notre cerveau
s’arrête de penser trop vite.
Dès qu’il a trouvé une solution
à peu près acceptable,
par souci d’économie d’énergie,
il s’arrête.
C’est d’ailleurs ce contre quoi on lutte
lorsqu’on utilise
des outils de créativité.
Et il y a nos processus cognitifs,
nos raccourcis de pensée qui,
parfois, nous font agir de manière
irrationnelle, nos fameux biais cognitifs,
comme le biais de cohérence
ou le biais de confirmation,
dont vous avez déjà entendu parler
et qui naturellement font
que notre cerveau
va aller chercher des informations qui
confirment ou maintiennent la cohérence
de notre représentation de la réalité,
sans jamais vraiment
la remettre en question.
Le problème de cette addiction,
c’est que ça peut nous jouer des tours
lorsque nous devons collaborer
avec d’autres personnes,
lorsque nous devons évaluer une situation,
lorsque nous devons prendre une décision.
Prenons l'exemple de la prise de décision.
Imaginez que vous allez faire
une décision d’investissement :
acheter une voiture, acheter un logement
ou dans le monde de l’entreprise,
acheter un logiciel conséquent :
une solution marketing
ou une solution de gestion
relation client,
ou même faire l’acquisition
d’une autre société.
Alors forcément, pour faire ce choix,
vous allez définir des avantages,
des inconvénients,
une liste multicritères, complexe
ou simple, selon votre décision.
Mais surtout, ce que vous allez faire,
c’est chercher à répondre à une question :
cet investissement va-t-il être
un bon investissement ?
Cette voiture va répondre à mes besoins ?
Ce logement va-t-il me permettre
d’atteindre les objectifs ?
Ce logiciel va-t-il nous permettre
d’être plus productifs ?
Cette acquisition va-t-elle être
une bonne acquisition
et créer de la valeur
pour les actionnaires ?
Mais ainsi vous portez votre attention
sur le terme bon investissement,
qui devient votre réalité,
même si elle n’est que supposée.
Parce que votre cerveau s’arrête
un peu trop tôt,
parce que vous avez le biais
de confirmation ou de cohérence,
vous risquez fortement de minimiser
certains inconvénients
parce que vous allez vous focaliser
uniquement sur les bons côtés de la chose.
Et du coup, vous risquez de
manquer complètement certains risques.
Soit vous les sous-estimez,
soit vous n’imaginez même pas
qu’ils puissent exister.
Une augmentation du prix
du carburant, par exemple,
ou un dégât des eaux qui empêche
la location de votre logement,
un problème de gestion des droits
et des données privées,
ou un modèle de distribution
qui ne colle pas tout à fait
à notre logistique actuelle.
Et du coup,
vous déséquilibrez fortement
les critères de votre prise de décision.
Pour résoudre ce problème,
il faut aller chercher la contradiction.
Il faut même se forcer
à dépasser nos illusions
pour pouvoir lutter
contre l’addiction de notre cerveau.
En prise de décision,
un outil qui peut être intéressant est
celui proposé par le psychologue Klein
et qui s’appelle le « pre-mortem ».
Dans le pre-mortem, vous commencez
comme pour toutes vos autres décisions,
vous analysez les avantages,
les inconvénients,
vous établissez votre liste
multicritères, tout pareil.
Et lorsque vous pensez
avoir fait votre choix,
stop !
Vous ne prenez pas
tout de suite votre décision.
Vous imaginez que
vous prenez cette décision,
que vous faites le choix
qui vous semble le plus opportun
et vous vous projetez dans le futur.
Six mois, un an, cinq ans, dix ans.
Vous vous projetez dans le futur
et vous imaginez que votre décision,
que votre choix est un échec total.
Ce n’est que de l’imagination.
Mais imaginez que c’est un échec.
Une fois que vous avez imaginé ça,
vous pouvez vous poser la question :
pourquoi cet échec est-il arrivé ?
Et vous voyez qu’en faisant
ce petit exercice,
vous vous forcez à chercher
la contradiction,
vous vous forcez à dépasser l’addiction
de votre cerveau
et du coup, de facto, en fait,
vous enrichissez votre réalité
petit à petit
et vous êtes capable de rééquilibrer
les critères de votre prise de décision.
Dans notre monde, vous pouvez
penser que tout est binaire.
Ai-je raison ?
Ai-je tort ?
Ceci est-il une illusion ?
Ceci est-il la réalité ?
Je pense qu’une meilleure
question à se poser, c’est :
cette illusion me sert-elle ?
Cette illusion me dessert-elle ?
Et lorsque cette illusion me dessert,
alors je dois savoir quoi faire
pour lutter contre l’addiction
de mon cerveau envers cette illusion.
Parce que c’est en sachant lutter
contre l’addiction de mon cerveau
envers cette illusion,
que je vais pouvoir enrichir
ma réalité petit à petit
et ainsi dépasser mon illusion.
Parce que mes chers amis du TEDx Limoges,
la vraie magie, elle est peut-être là.
Elle est peut-être dans notre capacité
à dépasser nos illusions,
à lutter contre l’addiction de notre
cerveau envers ses propres illusions
et ainsi être capable de mieux collaborer
avec d’autres personnes,
être capable de mieux
évaluer les situations
et être capable de prendre
de meilleures décisions.
Et donc, mes amis de TEDx Limoges,
maintenant, c’est à vous de jouer !
(Applaudissements)